pop
[Musique]
oh
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma chère soeur ainsi c'est un fait
accompli de ce jour de ouallam marier ce
matin tu as fait femme devant la loi ce
soir te feras femme devant la nature et
par balles
combien cette pensée me trouble moi qui
sait de quoi il retourne
[Applaudissements]
et je ne suis pas près de toi lors d'une
pareille épreuve hélas un océan nous
sépare veut du moins que ma voix
traversent les mers pourtant donné les
conseils de même tu vas connaître le
grand mystère
à quoi rêvent les jeunes fait qu'est ce
que tu fabriques et tétouan dos
messieurs à la grâce d'une pâte terme
d'un chien comment veux tu que je parle
au feu de grange maman de ton
phonographe at on idée telle invention
de choisir le salon pour parler dans le
phonographe
c'est extraordinaire cette manie tu
parles est une popote terre voilà six
largages un père dit non quand dix de
retrouvées les premières scènes dit que
des bêtises et toi aussi
enfin tu bats je suis en train de parler
dans mon instrument et qu'est ce que tu
lui disait un point d'instruments plus
disait je disais rien seulement tu
arrives là se prononcer le discours que
j'ai préparé pour caro lieu à l'occasion
de son mariage avec son âne qui doute
mais à jacasser naturellement le feu
n'est grave ce pauvre à paris qu'il ne
sait pas lui il ne distingue pas il
enregistre ce qu'ils ont trop elle est
bien bonne alors tout ce que nous avons
dit ça y est mesdames on au maitien
situe en doute ma chère soeur ainsi ces
deux raids a conduit de ce jour voilà
ce matin là cette femme devant la loi
ce soir deux fera femme devant la nature
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi qui sait de quoi il retourne
le voilà tu m'as oui et je ne suis pas
près de toi lors d'une pareille épreuve
dès lors en océan nous sépare du moins
que ma voix traverser les mers pourtant
donné les conseils donnerais tu à
connaître le grand mystère
à coire et les jeunes filles qui voient
là relate on oeuvre n'est jamais bien
beau tout ça
oh mon nom non me dis tout de suite il
m'a jamais dit du faudra pas tomber
cette invention idiote qui serait idiot
j'ai dit at on idée de cette invention
idiote de choisir le salon pour parler
dans le phonographe repas me faire dire
ce que je n'ai pas dit ça c'est un
détail c'est pas sa faute et lui j'avais
couple la tendre ses ports aux stay
c'est comme ça qu'on fait des potages je
te fais c'est exclu en date on si leurs
atouts leur commencera d'autant que ça
ne sera pas un mal
si ça te permet de supprimer ta phrase
sur les maires sur les mecs je veux que
ma voix à travers sa lé maire pourtant
donné les conseils de mer où se trouve
sa spirituel pourquoi c'est drôle c'est
une saillie m'a justement on n'en voit
pas une saillie pour le mariage de sa
soeur
c'est un frère que ça car mon charmant
c'est comme ce qui suit ce matin tu as
fait femme devant la loi ce soir tu
feras femme devant la nature enfin tu
trouves ça convenable à dire une jeune
fille et je lui dis ce qui doit lui
arriver mais la pop donne toi elle s'en
apercevra bien non
ferrat des secours à une jeune mariée
pour lui dire des cochons [ __ ]
le choix dont tranquille tu n'entends
rien alors des préparations à l'eva non
plus tout mettre à table
oui bengtsson qu'on observe jeu philippe
déjà depuis un bon moment et tu n'as pas
commencé il n'y a pas de maison possible
c'est monsieur des jeunes à une heure et
madame la lune ont battu avec un matin
je n'ai pas pu rentrer plus tôt à passer
ça c'est moi qui suis dans grand tort je
suis étonné madame coudray déjeuner très
bien enfin qu'est ce que tu peux faire
c'est tous les jours la même chose tu es
sorti depuis neuf ans est heureux ça m'a
permis de rentrer - t'as vraiment c'est
à se demander à quoi au nommé mais
qu'est ce que tu vas encore d'imaginer
nommé non mais dis tout de suite que
j'ai à la main 9 la motion hamon
maintenant ça veut dire maintenant ma
pauvre enfant je sais très bien que la
panda mans un amant toi je suis bien
tranquille
et pourquoi ce que je n'aurais pas
l'amant est bien parce que parce qu'il y
à des femmes qui sont faites pour avoir
des amants et d'autres kaenel saurons
enfin je n'ai pas vécu cinq ans avec 302
connaîtra son toit un avant un lot dont
tu as une preuve petite femme une bonne
mère de famille à qui il ne manque que
des enfants pour l'être tout à fait mais
ça ça n'est pas notre faute et puis
enfin enfin tu n'apportes tempérament de
diable je le suis assez comme ça je ne
vais pas te le dire parce que tu me
force et bah oui là j'ai un amant à et
bien tu lui diras bien des choses de ma
peur
un avant-toit tiens tu veux que je te
dise tu t'avances oui madame c'est très
humiliant mais vous n'êtes qu'une autre
il faut s'entendre dit le bourget
résonance et non onze comme la vie en
face le train avant si maillard as tu
vas bien tiens tu es une grosse bête
monsieur c'est un monsieur qui demande
monsieur hubert temps qu'est ce qu'il me
veut enfin cette entrée via kies à un
collègue du crb c'est certain bonjour
mon cher aux gens se marient
[Musique]
je suis ouverte à un camarade du
sporting madame chan a notamment chanté
c'est moi croyez bien si je ne me trompe
nomme il me semble que ce n'est pas la
première fois que vraiment monsieur
habré vous voyez plus je vous regardez
plus cher est-ce que vous ne connaissez
pas quelqu'un dans ma maison mon dieu
monsieur sait que j'ignore où vous
demeurez à 21 heures et du colisée and
on and on and on vous fait dire pour
finir oui vous faites l'erreur ne me
connais son père ça un pardon erreurs
des paccots et qu'est ce qui me vaut
votre visite vous ne donnez pas les
dettes de jeu se fait dans les 24 heures
et je suis votre débiteur ne fallait pas
vous déranger pour ça ce sont là des
règles qui seront faites pour les
professionnels elles ne sauraient avoir
force de loi aux trois gens qui se
connaissent se dit tous les bons comptes
font les bons amis et bree boulet
boureij et quelques scrupules à
considérer la partie que nous avons fait
ensemble comme bien régulière et il me
paraît que nous n'avons pas joué tout à
fait à chances égales
pourquoi dans sa vie je ne sais pas mais
il me semble qu agent me comprends parce
que j'étais face à annaba non non je
n'ai pas dit que 90 ans laissait dont
l'essai dont j'ai le courage de béate
oui madame j'ai pris l'habitude tout les
jours à 4h 5h d'avoir de thé gores
civils ce n'est pas du vif chez moi
n'est ce pas ceux de l'américain à la
wii l'espace et le temps frais des
affaires en amérique et là bas et qui
dit à faire dit pas tout se traite ont
risqué alors qu'est ce que vous voulez
il a bien fallu que je me mette au
diapason pour mes affaires
seulement voilà où nous sommes en état
d'infériorité nous autres français
l'américain lui dit oui ce cri de
swiss-ski à sa mairie fait rien il jouit
d'un privilège
malheureusement moins vite j'ai la tête
française cette naissance
alors j'ai pu peu un peu naturalisé mon
estomac mais massacré caboche qui
allaitaient patriotes mais jamais rien
voulu savoir
de la sorte qu'aujourd'hui il ya un
antagonisme entre ces deux parties de
mon individus mon estomac qui est devenu
américain des sénateurs réclament ces
whisky et ma tête
elles survivent du conflit et finalement
comme s'il mate est la plus faible m
c'est toujours les petits qui faiblit
voilà voilà voilà voilà
comme vous le voyez madame rocha est
tout à fait spéciale mais on ne peut pas
dire
que je vaux chardon jeune américaine ou
non c'est tout à fait autre chose
fabrice lhomme et bien ma foi en dieu
messieurs je n'aurais pas osé mais du
moment je vous le dit je dois avouer que
je la comprends mais oui n'est ce pas
voilà une femme qui vous savez le 10 12
whisky comme ça ça déchire
c'est une américaine paraît alors sanaa
mais je dois voir que moi ça me fiche
partage évidemment
évidemment nous disions donc je voudrais
combien 35 oui je crois
n'est ce pas alors il faudra six mille
fois et pour en revenir à la question de
jeu que votre délicatesse d'un sommet
3-1 des mois je me sens sûr que quand je
suis dans les parcs dans l'état qu'à
vous savez je suis tout aussi du site à
l'état normal je ne suis même davantage
je vois double au câble c'est
quelquefois meuf et pour compter les
points
pas du tout du tout jeune c'est pas vrai
alors rien de plus simple je divise par
deux camps les frais les faits mais nous
disons mille francs que je vais vous
cherchez votre bonheur monsieur
koudougou au sty elle fait entrer mais
quelques roustes games est lui même le
sol costaud lui le député le vix garde à
l'opposition
le fameux tribune et que je suis heureux
j'admire tellement son éloquence vous
permettez de commandos entre mon vieux
justement parlé de toi
l'ess etienne fermera ça va bien mais
pas mal merci et bbv ni madame
naturellement je devrais content de
connaître depuis tant que tu la croche
chaque fois que tu entres dans ce salon
ça finit par avoir l'air d'être de
l'adresse et tu sais hélas ne tremble
pas aussi c'est toi qui le trouble
toujours monsieur postule ne vous
occupez palais ce que vous dit mon mari
et venez pas dire bonjour la durée qu'on
peut être posée dans votre chaise
monsieur pousse tous dit oui au pardon
paix quelle petite madame gervais a non
non non c'est le contraire
aa oui bon vin ça va bien je présente
monsieur guy bertin qui désire vivement
faire ta connaissance aaa
certes internet et moi monsieur de me
dire un de vos plus fervents admirateurs
à bbb et bbb
me dupont ce danseur voyons de quoi tu
leur as we le pont à monsieur au pardon
excusez moi mais ce que c'est c'est des
branches e cd des asperges merci je vois
bien j'avais pas pris ça pour des cannes
à cela en voilà une idée de se promener
avec sa maison à cette fois les asperges
monsieur coustous y est alors quoi eh
bien tu sais c'est pour se donner une
contenance à voile à ouvrir enfin tu
n'es pas fou tu sais que tu déjà
emprunté dans tes mouvements mais tu vas
te coller une botte d'aspergés sous le
bras pour faire tes vieilles me saleh
maddon déposer sa dentition a fait à
bordeaux
bravo on n'a pas idée de timides comme
ça mais j'en suis à ivry vous savez
devant une assemblée personne n'est plus
à l'aise c'est un foudre des locaux il
est là devant nos droits plus personne
arrivée timide au singulier et audacieux
pur guerre voilà moi si ça n'est pas le
moyen de
être à son aise que de le taquiner tout
le temps at et voilà qu à des pauses et
abbott a appris à me bats tu ne te sens
pas plus à l'aise comme ça aussi pour
madame oui mais non à la minute
alphonse et postule au monsieur
coopération comme on se tait pour nous
comme en convient et moi qu'il blaguait
tout à l'heure parce que tu étais
grotesque avec 7 est pour nous une botte
d'aspergés au mois de mars
c'est de la folie tu sais mais c'est
rageant d'huile on met tout sur les
faces pour ce soir et vous viendrez la
manger avec ses ça et moi pendant ce
temps je vais chercher votre emmené dans
une prendre pour un imbécile qui vous
rend heureux c'est ce qu'estime il est
possible que j'aie pu en avoir l'air
et vous saurez que je ne suis pas
monsieur jamais jusque là ça va bien
pour traoré moi si je suis un bébé cyr
et je voudrais bien que quelqu'un vienne
me le dire en face
j'espère voir si je suis en rdc vous
mais tout le monde le sait bien
ouah je suis jeune et décide non non non
non non mais que l'on peut dire ou un
imbécile mais mais mais qui pourrait
penser semble hélas au bout tu soutenais
ministère ou de renverser comme un
château de cartes
selon gaza selon le ministère ah j'ai
l'air d'un imbécile je vais voir moi
commun aux ministères
si je suis en abc il aux femmes sous la
joie et tout ce qui n'est jamais vous ne
me connaissez pas je me retournais à
trélut jarry ce que je lui dirai h en
juillet mais pas les faits mais qu'est
ce que criait comme ça c'est vous
monsieur annoncé monsieur qui part en
tapinois messieurs pousse tout vu ça
n'est pas passé alors monsieur costaud
duel devant la fois je regrette de ne
pas avoir été là pour la rareté
différentes de personnages ouais si cher
monsieur rockeuse louis avec tous mes
remerciements et mon nom c'est moi au
contraire voir cher monsieur vous partez
billet je vous laisse j'ai dit en avoir
pour affaires et il vaut mieux que ce
soient des bois maintenant qu'après cinq
heures
ça ne vous dit monsieur très honoré
d'avoir faire votre connaissance et ben
il faut redescendre
monsieur qui est très honoré et c'est au
pardon il muscle à la bonne heure pour
madame monsieur
et bien va déjeuner fonderie j'y vais
j'y vais et puis quand même donc au
studio avec toi j'ai mon cylindres à
faire ça ne l'amuserait prenez monsieur
coup stocker je vous emmerde
attention à la chaîne ma chère ce ainsi
c'est un fait accompli de ce jour 2
voilà marié mais allez-vous vous taire
non donnant mais monsieur yan afin vous
voyez pas que je parle mais à qui est ce
que ça vous regarde pas vous en tout cas
c'est à croire que c'est une gageur ma
parole madame d'abord vous après
monsieur bah quoi qu'est ce que vous me
voler monsieur c'est un monsieur qui
désire parler à mme bachelot fiche de
votre monsieur il m'embête
qu'est ce qu'il me veut voici sa carte
et je m'en fiche de sa carte comme de
lui je suis pour personne n'entendait
allait aller lui dire qu'il m'embête
vraiment on fut monsieur de voir que je
vous dérange
1 on n'est pas du tout monsieur
et je vous en prie je peux revenir du
tout du tout mais qu'est ce qui peut
vous faire supposer comment dont on
n'est pas plus aimable
et qu'y at il pour notre service et bien
monsieur chat nam que j'ai l'honneur de
parler parfaitement ce chenal
propriétaire de cet immeuble
oui enfin l'immeuble appartient à ma
femme mais étant chef de la communauté
bientôt même et bien voici monsieur j'ai
vu que vous aviez l'entresol à louer en
effet même si je cherche justement à un
pied-à-terre et cet appartement
conviendrait à vous l'avez visiter nos
longs stupidement un conte bien comme ça
il est deux leaders ah oui pardon eh
bien il est de 3000 en fait on 4000 en
chiffres au jeudi mettons 4000 comme en
étant 4 me vous ne m'avez pas compris je
vous ai dit s'il serait plus commode
4000 c'est clair c'est net c'est
divisible par quatre ça fait mille
francs par trimestre par calcul a fait
on sait toujours ce qu'on a donné
j'aime mieux ça on le sait - soit 4000
qu'est ce que ça vous fait à moi à rien
du tout enfin pour quatre villes je ne
veux pas vous contrarier
on n'est pas plus aimable a maintenant
s'il ya des réparations à faire je m'en
charge
mouss seulement laissez-moi vous avertir
d'une chose oui à vous voir si
arrangeant il m'est permis de supposer
qu une arrière-pensée quad on est bien
voilà je comprends très bien qu'un homme
jeune mon dieu on n'est pas de bois mais
je voulais l'immeuble et entama femmes
sur la question de moralité l'homme
enfin au terme du bail vous devez
habiter bourgeoisement référé ainsi
qu'aux plantes en a une et nullement
l'intention d'amener des dames du dehors
mon dieu vous savez entre nous il ne
faudrait pas prendre non plus au pied de
la lettre ils viendraient une dame par
asada mais non mais non mais non mais je
ne dépassais pour vous inciter à mal
m'enfin vous auriez une relation que le
concierge n'a pas à savoir si c'est
votre mère ou votre sol mais aucune
relation pas plus avec ma mère qu'avec
passe faibles mais croyez bien que je
n'aie jamais s'y poser monsieur je vous
certifie que jamais votre concierge ne
verra après une femme chez moi chaque
maire alors monsieur v compliments je
vois que nous nous accorderons sans
peine dieu merci
si tous les locataires étaient en bout
le métier de propriétaires serait plus
agréable
bah vous savez tel qu'il est c'est
encore tout de même celui qui trouvera
que d'un matelas oui
il est drôle j'ai des beaux tout préparé
désirez vous que nous saignons tout de
suite prenantes y est oui ah si vous
voulez bien me donner votre nom mais sur
ma carte
or c'est juste evil massenet oui tiens
non homonyme wind joie mais non c'est
comme ça qu'on l'a fait tout le temps
massenet moss m'a dit mais vous n'avez
pas été élève à saint louis à ce
jusqu'en seconde c'est ça mais moi aussi
quand chanal culte en rappel pacha naja
l'attendaient dont chan mais si voyons
aux idiomes dit oh pardon
maintenant je vous en prie mon nom du
moment qu'on a été camarades sur le
moment n'est ce pas ça sur moi alors tu
disais donc idiot à la valeur toujours
le même vieux copain je disais tu ne te
rappelles penche annales tant on sait
pas un grand dont on disait que le père
était connu mais non c'est moi
partant de cette fois puisque je suis
ici quoi vais je la fais à la bonne
heure tu me reconnais maintenant mais
moi c'est un plaisir de narnia pas quand
on a usé ses culottes ensemble au
collège et qu'on se retrouve est venu
c'est non mais hausse mais de nouvelles
connaissances dans la vie mais un
camarade d'enfance ça ne se fait pas
non surtout à nos âges c'est vrai sable
pas dit non c'est loin tout sera ça nous
rajeunit part entière assieds toi non
merci merci à ce boom affleck
dis donc tu te rappelles bourrache que
tu es si rigolo
oui les vents je le vois quelques fois
il n'a pas changé figure toi toujours
aussi rigolo allons doha oui il est
huissier assez joyeux en effet les bains
et pour tous tu te rappelles poteau non
mais si tu avais une soeur qui venaient
le voir au parloir une sortie nous
faisait de l'oeil
allons voyons même qu'elle louchet ça
lui permettait de faire de l'oeil à deux
élèves à la fois tu ne te rappelles pas
poteau à quel c'est drôle hein ah ben il
est mort
pour tous est mort au pauvre poteau oui
c'est triste un autre à orly et de quads
une affection au coeur
ton coeur pour une actrice qui avait
trop de tempérament c'est ça qui l'a tué
un jour après déjeuner pour lui avais
pourtant dit que sur la digestion à
diana diana da graça n'a pas traîné
il a été enlevé la blanc sur le coup sur
le coup à rebours vos photos quelle
histoire
l'édile en au fait qu'est ce que tu me
choque mais t'as pas pu le connaître
poteau comme enjeu qu'on peut connaître
photo mais c'est à henri iv que j'ai été
avec lui à bon port battant mieux aux
barbes alors bon ben alors je m'en fous
tout ça parce qu'ils soient morts poteau
on va célébrer puisqu'il était henri iv
on va dire que du collège voix pour
ainsi dire plus personne n'y en a guère
cas avec les et conserver des relations
mais à café songe pas à celui là je sais
pas si tu t'en souviens c'est le député
coustous you costaud nul je te croyais
les tissus ici oui mon train de tenir
compagnie à la fin mais c'est un de mes
amis intimes il ne décolle pas de la
maison assez curieux à moi je suis très
lié avec lui il m'a jamais parlé de toi
on va cependant as tu le connais et bien
malheureux crois tu que son amour le met
dans un état son amour au et l'anamour
temps n'a pas parlé non mais il parle
que de ça un amour sans espoir on m'a
par exemple et pour qui enfin je sais
que c'est une femme mariée voilà tout
coustous lui c'est la discrétion même
hymne entretien de ses intrigues mais
anonymement et bâillements n'a pas
ouvert la bouche longs mois et qui
plaide de faire des cachoteries avec
noir sans compter que tout ce qui
n'arrivera à regret c'est bien ce qu'il
en rage au moins moi j'aurais pu être de
bon conseil
je lui aurais dit ce qu'il y avait à
faire je connais la fin tu la connais
non non je connais la femme en général
je ne sais pas moi j'aurais été le
clairon qui sonne la charge
vraiment mort ketchup la ville ont plus
de coeur au ventre
j'aurais même dit la chose plus crûment
la la c'est au contraire pas du tout ce
qu'ils avaient à dire et bac s qu'ils
gênent le mari d'abord la belle affaire
quand tu aurais un cocu pourrait pas le
faire médian qui n'est même pas un
garçon il n'a pas de chance quand il est
amoureux il ya plus personne tant qu'il
n'est pas arrivé à ses fins il est comme
un idiot et naturellement par ça ferait
si froid quand il est commun dit aux
élèves passaient ce qui fait qu'il
suffit qu'il soit épris d'une femme pour
être sûr de se brosser torgau graves et
aux enfants tous avec la femme mariée en
question il paraît que le fait pas plus
attention à 8,6 n'existait pas elle
alors lui quand elle est là il est
annihilé une nouvelle de la fouille
rouge il sait plus quoi dire
enfin il sait pas où se mettre oui je
vois ça tu sais il est comme ça ici et
là qui habite hype
non on me dit non non non non si avec ce
très beau mais celle là lors la femme
mariée
c'est peut-être ma femme à femme mais
oui son trouble devant elle
c'est un feuillage mais je m'explique la
presse que tu vas imaginer dans l'est
dont ça n'a pas d'importance je trouve
ça très drôle au contraire en somme quoi
il est amoureux de ma femme et marc
bellemare l'a tant que ça ne va pas plus
loin
et comme ma femme est une femme honnête
of wheat on sait rien toi non tu dis ça
par politesse oui oui mais moi je le dis
parce que je la connais donc de ce côté
là je veux bien tranquille d'autre part
coustous nu pendant joue notant que je
verrai papouilles avec ma femme je
pourrais être tranquille comme baptiste
ans comme tous les bâtisses très nul
sauf que c'est drôle et costumes
amoureux de la femme il faut que je lui
dire ça pour la ferme alors aussi et
surtout pas moi tout ça parce que lui ne
me pardonnerai pas bon voyons ça va sans
dire
le pauvre garçon il en aurait une
plongée sur wii comme croûte au bas du
dos et préventives scénarii
naturellement francis toi et bien vient
à quoi tu estimes yao on auprès de toi
tombe et on a manqué pourquoi au nom tu
ne devinera jamais c'est vrai émile
massenet mon ami menace le trésor us
monsieur vous portez là nous voilà ça y
est est ce que vous êtes parent du
musicien lance non madame n'est pas cet
honneur non mon nom s'écrit à y je le
regrette pour voudra aussi madame b
c'est la faute à la y/y quoi y cmh net à
l'air étonné massenet qui sort de saint
louis est ici moi je ne sais pas ce que
je viens d'apprendre
tiens toi bien coustous lui est amoureux
de toi qu'est ce qui t'a dit ça ben
c'est massenet messieurs banana
j'ai pas fait quelque chose que je ne
savais pas jeter simplement confié que
coûte ou nul était tellement amoureux
d'une femme mariée que lorsqu'il était
dans sa présence il venait complètement
idiot alors toi là dessus tu m'as
répondu c'est ma femme on sait pas la
même chose robot quoi ça revient au même
débat
j'espère qu'on est là une bonne tu
penserais jamais douté moi mais je
laisse ça fait quoi tu savais qu'il
était amoureux de toi dame mais c'est
pas possible tu te fais des déclarations
mais c'est bien pour ça on peut douter
de l'amour d'un homme qui vous dis je
vous aime
on ne peut pas douter de l'amour de
celui qui fait tout pour le café eh ben
je m'étais jamais aperçue de rien
évidemment toi tu es samarie tu ne peux
pas avoir la prétention de vin les
choses avant les autres
vous êtes constit madame non non non non
on en est là un peu raison mais
maintenant il ya un tas de choses qui
m'ouvre les yeux qu'un tout à l'heure
les asperges les aspects oui et l'autre
à jour les brugnons cigare toi ma fan
d'ac acheter un mot en l'air devant lui
dira j'ai vu de beaux brugnon chez intel
nous tiens je mangerais bien des
asperges traque deux heures après tu
vois revenir mon costume avec une
corbeille de brugnons ou une botte
d'aspères bref je n'ose plus rien dit et
y'a pas un il fait ça que pour elle
qu'un mois l'autre jour j'avais des
douleurs dans le ventre
ge a dit devant lui à j'aimerais bien
avoir un kata place n'a pas bronché
ça aura été pour ma femme oh la la il
aurait plutôt poser lui même père
d'ailleurs tu auras l'occasion
d'observer maintenant que nous allons
nous revoir car tu ne sais point
massenet je viens de lui louer
l'entresol bas ou fait il faut bien
préparer le bike du mathan cinq minutes
je t'en prie et bien donné vous
mutuellement compagnie je reviens dans
un instant
fallou et l'autre sens vous vous changez
comme c'est gentil il s'est pas jetée
puis s'ils tombent les fière d'être venu
chez moi rue du colisée
si tremblante à penser que peut-être on
a des intérêts comme j'avais raison
regarde un peu juste un ami de mon mari
qui demeure dans la maison quand oui et
il m'a vu entrer ou sortir alors la
fâcheuse gâvres heureusement mon mari
n'a pas fait attention
non enfin battu tout de même si par
hasard on n'en parle pas mais maintenant
plus rien de tout cela n'est à craindre
plus de risque d'être compromise
tu n'auras plus à sortir de chez toi
nous nous aimerons ici dans la maison
c'est bien plus pratique et beaucoup
plus convenable pour mon mari ma chérie
je t'aime
francine après il est certain qu'on
galeries lafayette le sort des
demoiselles de m
je suis toujours là c'est vous monsieur
poste auprès de toi qu'est ce que tu
fais ici
eh ben tu vois je suis venu rendre
visite à mon ancien camarade de collège
canal qui m'a fait l'honneur de me
présenter à madame chan avait des délais
donnés sur ce n'est nous a présenté
merci c'est fait mais pourquoi tu là
c'est troubler moi pas mais c'est faux
je te défends donc qu'est ce que tu vas
croire ce n'est pas elle
moi ça n'est pas ça mais ça n'est pas
moi qui crois monsieur costiou aa non
non non non non non non rien rien du
tout vous apprêtiez à sortir mais
surtout si vous avez affaire d'ars ne
vous dérangez pas pour nous permettre
[Rires]
qu'est ce que nous disions non môssieur
masse qu'est ce que nous visions monde
mon dieu qu'est ce que nous pouvions
bien terrien ah oui vous me disiez
madame que vous aviez remarqué un melon
chez potel et chabot et qui vous avait
cette envie un mail en moi si vous
permettez en sortant d'ici je cours chez
potel et je voulais rien rien du tout
madame derrière j'en reviens je viens et
voilà c'est pas plus mal
sam kd l'esprit la mourante ingénieux le
thème si tu savais comme je suis
heureuse depuis 24 heures depuis que
c'est fait j'ai envie de crier mon
bonheur à tout le monde aux passants aux
domestiques à mon mari non on ne craint
rien renchérit ce sont les envies qu'on
aille qu'on ne se passe pas et pourtant
il ya des moments où ça me brûle le lui
raconter c'est si lourd à garder un
secret puis je me dis que ça le rendrait
furieux qui me prête une scène et comme
faisant une sinistre est bien forcé de
parler de toi et c'est si bon d'entendre
prononcer le nom de celui qu'on aime
oui je sais j'ai pas le droit il ne faut
pas penser qu'à soi dans la vie mon mari
aurait de la peine et ne méritent pas au
nom car aux falcons garçon n'est pas de
sa faute
qui ça il n'est pour gagner beaucoup
quel dommage qu'on ne puisse pas avoir
un amant sans tromper son mari
ah oui mais ça ça gâte la moitié du
plaisir au paddock vraiment regarder mes
yeux si j'ai des regrets c'est à dire
pourtant que je ne voulais pas quand je
faisais les manières au fond tissage ne
pensait pas un mot mais n'est ce pas on
a reçu des principes on peut pas comme
ça des combles dans ma robe
il faut attendre orale heureusement tu
étais un homme mort
quand tu veux quelque chose toi tu sais
moi qui aurait été vexé c'est un mélange
chaud mais je répondrais n'est ce pas
d'abord si tu avais lâcher tant pis pour
ma pudeur de femmes je t'aurais couru
après hong kong
voyez vous ça si j'avais su qu'il ne
méprise pas or moi te méprise est ce que
c'est la première fois au but c'est ça
oui c'est ça promets moi qui n'a jamais
confié belle trame est moi qui ne
trompera jamais je t'aime tu me rendrai
folamour la brouillade ça les ports est
longtemps alors véronique rami hier et
bien encore ce soir ils ont peu et bien
à toi ça je me suis ménagé une sortie
j'ai prévenu mon mari que je dînais chez
maman et je donne avec elle au théâtre
non jusqu'à une heure du matin par
ferrara seulement ce soir il faudra
repasser par le 21 de la rue du colisée
a aujourd'hui je suis plus aguerris et
puis en amour comme en amour je t'adore
il est certain qu'on galeries lafayette
le sort des 3l de magasins qu'elle
lurette en bail
quelle durée 90 ans
tu es foutu 3 en veux-tu 6 or s'est
passé et bien 12 ans renouvelable tous
les trois ans est à volonté sol soit
pour commencer bon cinq minutes et bien
continuer à causer fait l'attraction
montgaillard
travailleur au mans femme mon mari oui
aux français mano en sucre non en chine
12h06
ou bien des enfants ce n'est pas
justement nous avions peu dit quelque
chose
oui mais quoi
mais n'importe quoi alors c'était un bon
laisser n'est ce pas que le lycée saint
louis
oh oui
superbe il fut fondée par hubert
d'harcourt d'où selon primitif de l'iss
et d'harcourt qu'il ne quitte à caen 18
128 reprendre celui de lycée saint louis
qui est son nom actuel
dans le grand vestibule d'honneur deux
portes de bois sculpté portant le nom de
ses fondateurs rappel à la génération
actuelle comme ça mais qu'est ce qui te
prend d'avoir ce ton élégiaque pour
faire l'historique du lycée saint louis
qui moi bah oui toi tu ne t'entends pas
non tu dis dans le grand vestibule
d'honneur
2 le porte de bois sculpté portant gravé
le nom de ces fonds nous serons d'accord
tu en appelant la boue sur youtube
on n'était pas perçu tulle m dans bien
notre avis et offre aux tiens voilà les
beaux je les ai signé tu n'as qu'à en
faire autant parfaitement une plume on
en croit une façon de faire les affaires
communes sa tête reposée et si nous
sommes d'accord tu n'as qu'à envoyer un
exemplaire avec la sig est tu voudras
pas vu cet avantage de ton temps aux
hommes et une abuse pas aytus est ravi
de t'avoir relever tout comme moi madame
très honoré de vous avoir été présenté
j'espère monsieur puisque nous devons
être voisin que nous ferons plus ample
connaissance
référencement
on voir toi au revoir toi madame tenez
reconduisez monsieur à bientôt à bientôt
[Applaudissements]
ja
retraite fabien ton ami n'est ce pas
qu'est-ce que tu penserais d'avoir des
relations avec lui
mais j'avais dit avant cette vague est
bon alors il ya tout cas marché n'a plus
qu'un tout petit on s'est tu me fais
plaisir
ah si c'est parce que s'il ne t'avais
pas plus on sait jamais avec les femmes
alors la latte et secteur mais on ya
vraiment pas de quoi mon m m'a alors dit
non non non pour l'amour de dieu laisse
ou à finir mon s'il a vendu 10 à dieu
parce que je vais sortir comme j'ai dit
chez maman et que je ne rentrerai pas
avoir le dîner mais dame benoiton à
lanvin ne rentre pas trop tard et après
le théâtre moment me remettre à la bombe
un rayon en suis-je moi avec tout ça
tiens j'ai donc pas arrêter le mouvement
je vais déjà les ravages
voyons ça à l'époque
on dit que c'est la voix de ma femme est
bien au nom de dieu
mais oui on met les hommes ont fini à
seulement ce soir 21 et du colisée c'est
le ciel qui écrit aussi aux lymphomes
rossi ne répondra pas la criminelle
la récidiviste etienne ben oui madame ou
et madame aux médias de sortir mais bon
c'est bien
bon allez vous aurez tarbes parti elle
ne tenait plus en place
elle avait installé le retrouver son
amant au sifflet tenaient tous les deux
mais lui nuit quel est il
voyons voyons dans tous ceux qui
viennent disent non c'est pas possible
messi pourtant le jésuite avec cette
timidité de comédie mais c'est tout ce
qu'on lui par bleus le voilà le dessous
des asperges
cette housse toulouse et moi tout le
temps tout le temps je te dis va 20 21
heures et du colysée avenue du colysée
où elle t'attend kissama fans bons
apôtres allez allez consommer l'adultère
y adultes et amis ce fait l'on traite 20
ans josh aryzta porter un melon est une
foot l'atalanta dieu car rêve que je
vous demande pardon j'ai pas fait exprès
mais ça soulage
à l'automne aux as et moi d'être là à
saint-jean-de-dieu le bal
[Applaudissements]
à toi là le ballon le ballon
santos dumont sans ton stylo sa balade
est là dans ma chambre et bien sûr mais
rien sur le cauchemar
sp si le voile à garga reste en
supprimant les mines les mine la
victoire 1000 r1
qu'est ce qui lie à ses bêtes ma femme
ne sais pas mais qu'est ce qu'elles ont
eu la garde cela que tu arrives et où
j'en ai des palpitations c'est vrai on
regarde regarde tout mon coeur et je te
demande pardon tu attends attends
attends je vais te donner un peu
d'autres fleurs d'oranger ça ne remet
pas non tu sais si tu est somnambule le
cbo non non non j'ai l'habitude de
dormir très peu couverts et toi tu as
voulu garder la couverture ou athées
alors moi ça ne manque pas ça me donne
le coche alors c'est ma faute ma pauvre
chérie je suis désolé ce temps pourrait
il voit tout temps plein pour un
cauchemar eh ben voilà une affaire
mêlant moi j'adore quand je partais ça
donne des réveils délice alors si c'est
du raffinement pièce que ça n'est pas
moi qui suis impardonnable avoir des
cauchemars quand je dormais dans tes
bras car nous avons dormi madame dans
les bras l'un glos ah oui comme un petit
mari est comme une petite femme au
ça ça je voulais je voulais ça m'a
semblé si baum à dormir ainsi gentiment
après avec la satisfaction de l'oubli du
devoir accompli
oui
comment changer de mon mari on va dit
dont j'espère c'est dans ces moments là
regretté qu'on savoure vraiment son
bonheur c'est ça mais il a avoué t c'est
le meilleur de l'amour aussi des amants
qui n'ont pas dormi ensemble c'est pas
des amants c'est des gens qui ont eu des
rapports et ça c'est ce qu'il ya de
moins bon dans l'amour l'instant tu sais
bien que tous les romans d'amour on voit
que ça mais c'est sûr fait la preuve
c'est qu'après il ya toujours alléger
maman d'un animal triste et commandites
us ariab ce qu'il est en piste et
attristé ça prouve bien que non c'est
pour ça que je dis qu'une bonne fortune
qui se réduit à l'indispensable fou ça
me fait l'effet d'un gourmet qui dînent
au buffet de la gare entre deux trains
il s'est nourri peut-être mais il n'a
pas dîné deux bidons pour quelqu'un qui
traitent les autres de refiler pas
qu'est ce que tu veux je passe par les
impressions n'avais je les analyse un
bon dodo comme ça outre la saveur qu'on
y trouve
eh bien ça donne tout de suite à l'amour
une petite allure conjugale qui le
relève
ça efface le côté clandestins et ça pour
une femme honnête c'est beaucoup plus
convenable en eau comme j'aime la
délicatesse de descente au sénégal de
même c'était écrit que des êtres
notamment ce sont ces choses fatale qui
se décide au premier regard
au fond s'il y avait une logique dans
ces choses là sescousse doogy qui doit
être l'élu car enfin depuis le temps
qu'ils se dessèchent
il pourrait invoquer les droits de
l'ancienneté eh ben non les gens pauvres
coustouges laisser sa place si tu veux
que j'aille donc tandis que toi la
première fois que je t'ai vu je ne te
connaissais pas qui ne me connaissaient
pas aider tout blanc
j'ai senti en moi quelque chose qui me
disaient voilà celui qui est toi même
maman tu t'es dit voilà celle que moi à
ne dit pas non c'est le fluide ça c'est
comme au telegraph
on frappe d'un côté ses enfants ça
corresponde au sommet beau être alors
qu'est-ce et moi dans une loge nos
regards se sont rencontrés et c'est sur
le champion quelque chose m'a dit voilà
celui positivement aux cherry bomb ans
et bourroches
et dire que si nous étions mariés ce
sera tous les jours comme ça mais au tu
es heureux toi tu es libre si j'étais
libre moi aussi tu mets poudre est tout
de suite eu comme ce serait gentil
pouvoir savourer son bonheur dans toute
sa plénitude
le temps qu'on veut et tant qu'on veut
n'avoir pas à se préoccuper du temps
canon de l'heure qu'il est mais oui
sans compter qu'il faudrait peut-être
songer à l'orchidée nous avons fait là
bon sommes et il faut pas oublier que la
banque la permission de théâtre aura
fait ne doit pas être loin de mille vies
et déjà y avait d'ailleurs à vue d'oeil
il est quoi la barre pour cible voilà
six jours du 29 octobre à 16 heures du
matin oui ça c'est pas facile n'avons
pas d'ordinateur mais qu'est ce que
j'aime mais pourtant thierry écoute
petit à petit à petit
non elles marchent marchent mais ne va
pas en vendre encore à peu près du temps
qu'on a donnée au centre on attend de 2
3 4 5 6
spec brasser tout ça fait à filles à la
ccb fusion du mali et moi donc à toi toi
toi tu n'es pas intéressant toi tu es ni
pour mon fils et ma femme tu es marié un
mois non la place les visiteurs 8 9
janvier il est marié mais cet enfant
mais je ne veux pas m mais mais mais
vous m'aviez dit que vous détestez dû
battre
sous compreniez pas pour ses prix dans
nos marques et à croquer avec votre
femme vous deviez t elle pas vous marier
c'est fou mais c'est fou c'est pas une
réponse ça s'est fini mon père mais
aussi pourquoi avez vous voulu dans mes
parents j'ai la même boîte a dormi tel
mandat sans dormir c'est tout autre
chose
non parce que comme résultat nous sommes
dans un joli pécule aux eaux
qu'est ce que ça fait uts
prague est mort tellement terrain qui
altèrent ne penser qu'à vous
effectivement je suis ton goût et on va
faire comment sortir de là écoutez bien
par plusieurs planches de sa luge en
bois pour y courir chez votre mère vous
êtes sensé oui si nous avons la chance
que votre mari ne nous est pas précédé
vous avez toute la vérité au diable à ma
mère jamais d'une mère est une femme est
une femme avait plus ou moins denses
évidemment maman dix amants
on sait bien que les mères de jeunes et
allemand
elle a pu avoir convié ses amis des amis
maintenant ça va pas non une mère elle
est présente un peu genre pour vous
saurez à ce sera votre complice elle
enverra immédiatement quelqu'un chez
votre mère pour lui dire que vous vous
êtes senti souffrance chez elle et
qu'elle vous a gardé la sienne qui m'a
puni d'avoir trahi mes deux fois mais
règlent en bleu ciel ne s'appelle pas
que ces choses-là royan ne changera pas
une boîte portois alors aujourd'hui
qu'elle ne prendrait plus jamais d'abord
au moins non plus à l'est moi non plus
[Applaudissements]
et tu es gay dans le puits à fred
on voit ici qu'est ce qu'elle a ma
lanterne
éclair à l'envers sam sonar champions je
suis un petit peu sous pas de recours
mais merci peu qu'est ce que je voulais
dire jamais la porte
c'est vraiment je sais pas c'est pas
parce qu'on est so qu'il faudrait plus
d'un au nom d'un chien qu'elle est loin
cette porte à l est
attends attends j'ai pas fini les
papilles attends je me maquille
maintenant il va quoi ton mac les
envolées
non non c est ce genre hier tu fais sont
étroites
oh ma chère nom d'un chien l'a fait ça
comme ça comme ça on est chez soi c'est
curieusement quand on l'a savons bien
des choses qui arrivent cas ces moments
là c'est pareil et l'on
moonlight ainsi un site du moins au
départ non je demeure au cinquième jeu
dé monter d'un étage et je suis chez moi
alors ça ça ce sont des choses n'aillent
jamais comment expliquez-vous ce l état
normal a un c'est pareil dit un des
liens d'entente et là toi ô y dort on
n'y fait pas très réussi j'ai dû prendre
mes allumettes bougies
toujours sur mon chemin tout cas des
monnaies de l'histoire elle témoigné
mais mon dieu que je suis sûr que je
suis saoul et bien accoucher mais c'est
pas quand tu répétera tout le temps que
tu es sous personne te dis le contraire
peindre dans les appareils deviennent
des amis l eau mais vraiment bon faut-il
zone est une bombe tout de même je me
suis déshabillé sans m'en apercevoir
elle va arriver retard puisque tu es
déshabiller le pas reste un poney en
bannière pour attraper fois alors que je
trouvais très jeunes touchés je vais
faire mon petit dodo et szeged hongrie
afrique
on
tiens j'ai grandi elle va être tombé sur
la vie
un homme dans le championnat ça monsieur
je suis content que vous dites avoir il
acheter mes vêtements par henin
mechmache sorte de dieu c'est un fou
vous allez aimer tellement j'ai peur
j'ai pas mais je peux pas m'en aller en
cale soir et même chez moi j'attends
il attendait c'est moi qui vais vous
sortirez vous dire on tient à cette
visite le puyehue acoustique lapcipp les
conseils des images imaginées par le
concierge qui n'a pas l'air de répondre
allez allez vous allez ouste allez-vous
selon la chaîne il est plus lourd que je
ne pensais pas la vérité est étonnant ce
qui se fait et fait donc pas lourd
non mais ça va pas
qu'est ce que vous attendez mais après
tout mais non c'est moi mais ça te
regarde et vois rouge à l'autre moyen
que l'on prête à la famille qu'est ce
que nous faisons c'est fou mais allez
donc chercher la bougie ou de demander
où on ne le voit pas ce coup quoi l'on
se soit dans la femme énergie la page et
fait chanter la presse avait pas moyen
de bateaux sans condition la jalousie on
va se mettre à l'abri mais vous ne
perdez rien pour attendre et sage
voilà voilà la manche et dieu sait mieux
que personne
bertin à l'ami de mon mari bastareaud
chamond mais je ne suis pas chez moi
mais c'est donc pas de cinquième manche
n'est pas factice et l'on conçoit mais
alors pourquoi je suis ici
pardon hein pourquoi qui va des voix
près de moi je vous en prie c'est pas
nous qui sommes allés chercher montanes
est pas mal à évoluer c'est fou
allez-vous-en nous sommes ici chez nous
vous entendez chez nous chez les gens
pour s'enrichir
à madame chan auquel charles manson et
biz vous allez bien madame chan moi
connaissons pas connu nous ne sommes pas
manhattan
non madame eva famille on repart deuil
excusez moi c'est quand on est sous bois
tout de travers ainsi moi je vous vois
comme ça encombre les vacances mais si
on envahit pas le domicile des gens
qu'on ne connaît pas si vous n'aviez pas
pris ma série reine oui oui puisque ma
clé à l'aide de réels efforts sera dans
quelques mois la saison c'est comme ça
jusqu'à demain le jeu sortait sa madame
chan cépages et madame madame chanal je
sais pas son petit nom le plaisir
d'aller chercher par la fenêtre comme on
allait comme ça les a ramassés en place
ensemble et vériste ont parlé est ce que
ces noms là j'ai une idée si on faisait
un bide
ça va durer encore ses plaisanteries un
vif émoi candidat dès lundi la tâche des
familles parce que moi je suis poli avec
toi ps d'abord écouté mon petit bonhomme
la patience a des limites je vous ai
déjà infligé une correction tout à
l'heure si vous voulez je recommence
les charges et on essaye bien de ça mais
alors tu veux passer à biya aura lors
les deux mois je peux pas les balkans
suisse ou sub l'un des bars voilà qu'est
ce que vous attendez
c'est la clé mon dieu mon dieu il a fait
dans la rue dans mon contrat nous sommes
à sa merci
nous sommes bien non alors ayez un
comédien non à monsieur motion de
soutien précieux nous avons plaisir à
être avec vous et nous espérons qu'elle
soit certainement une autre fois
l'espace sur mont-royal je ne suis pas
dans une tenue jugée à m'habiller
vous vous êtes en habits et moi je suis
en chemise et bab el mandeb et là on va
se déshabiller moi aussi d'avoir avant
tout il faut une police a pas des gens
sont restés couverts de runes médaillé
d'or à lyon initial
on sera plus à l'aise franchement
c'est insensé est ce que vous allez
donner la salle aux normes est écoulé
non
mais c'est le ciel qui l'envoie en
référé dans les quêtes nations du monde
c'est au nom de ces notions secours
après concierge
dites lui de monte avec les agents il ya
un flou chez moi supplie messieurs et on
prévient la police
vous pourrez la boetie saison passée à
londres
or d'audace et mon fils est comment
voulez-vous la porte est fermée
les agents vont venir je peux pas partir
en caleçon manhattan et ses vêtements
ils sont là qui me font rien et ses
vêtements vous avez raison vraiment pas
pourquoi je me joindrai réforme était
chez vous la chute carrément chez sa
fille
voilà
son pantalon est large est ce que vous
voulez nous ne sommes pas là pour faire
du chiffre
il est chez vous avez encore besoin de
mettre son corps mais après des années
d'inaction vais pas vous n'avez jamais
rien à vous au hall investir ce qu'est
ce que c'est que ça c'est le concierge
lentillons notamment que le terme était
terminée machar alors si vous aimez
qu'est ce que vous attendez on était
vous dire d'aller chercher les agents 1
mais oui il ya un flou chez moi un fou
quoi bon s'en aller au commissariat on
vous entendra ont fait consciemment que
sur murat il me dit qu'il n'a pas
d'argent sous la main
c'est pas moi qui peut le penser soulier
bonsoir aussi on n'a pas idée d'avoir
des souliers dans des circonstances
pareilles que vous voulez qu'on m'aide
on est bien on a des bottines n'a pas
aimé ça là là ça m'apprendra à pompe et
mon mari
qu'est ce que c'est que ça on doit
ouvrir au le commissaire c'est le
commissaire à la femme et l'homme s'est
alors bon j'ai pas la clé des jeunes
papas monsieur là la clé dans la poste
mon pantalon
non parce que mon pantalon et dans la
rue jean talon est dans la rue me suis
dit la vérité dans la rue la clé du
prochain
oui mais elle a ouvert d'un côté un peu
de frais de location voilà voilà voilà
voilà voilà voilà
entrez entrez de ce commissaire voilà ce
qu'on commence à les stopper mais
c'était la sellette
inutile de vous cacher madame ça n'était
pas construit vous entendez madame
monsieur quoi toi malheureux quoi qu'est
ce que tu vas encore imaginer
alors
non non je t'en ben rien mais seules
commissions paritaires c'est ça m'ira
c'est bien mais c'était bien je ne
m'abaisserai pas jusqu'à me disculper
constat fait monsieur cause pas
tellement dur que c'est embêtant
vous retenez c'est madame qui plus est
belle la france y benoiton femme jeanne
antoinette et vous monsieur le nom qu'on
prête ainsi dit emile massenet imaginait
mais non mais non c'est bien pour lui
quand huit ans rentiers demeurant 28
gauche et vous reconnaissez tous les
deux avoir été surpris en flagrant délit
ont reconnu certes ou encore davantage
ma foi je prends construit et exigent
donc demander plus que ça n'est ce pas
là mais cet ami serge et à m'habiller
par conséquent n'est ce pas mais comment
donc à nous tirer voudrait bien
seulement madame et monsieur patients
notre commissariat entre une heure et
deux ont signé le procès verbal de
constat que je vais faire préparer ses
salades vous avez des instructions à
donner si vous voulez ma compagne et
j'avoue le suis vous venez d'achever
mais c'est seulement tellement quoi
c'est mes souliers
vous n'auriez pas une corne
oui
wally oppal bon c'est bien vous voudrez
bien être à 1h au commissariat penser ce
banc d'essai le calice et je vous en
prie non je n'en ferai rien bouger de
chez vous quoi mais non je suis pas sûr
parce que je voulais rien que jamais
c'est du passé
vous vanter d'avoir mis dans une jolie
situation je me suis dit je suis désolée
si vous trouvez que ça arrange guère de
chance lui sourire amicaux st-gall en
tram entre les malheurs d'une femme
c'est le moi qui vis douars de
sauvegarde et qu'est ce que je pouvais
faire
etonnez-vous m'agacer avoue m'agacer
vous m'agacer finissent elle-même au
soulier c'est vite dit et si vous n'avez
pas de quoi vous me prenez une
fourchette une fourchette à sinceny
denham c'est élémentaire et défoncé que
j'en ai pas
ça veut dire à maman mais ça ne s'est
même pas que ça peut se chausser avec
une fourchette
les maniaques et je suis mal d'entre
vous qui vous a dit que délicieux notre
mari il m'avait dit balla rejoindre 21
rue du colisée et à l'instant robin
immédiat les lots avec son ami n'ont pas
donné assez des miens au maintien elle
avait un amant volcanisme
mais dire que c'est la la la la la la
voilà la moitié par des retards son
amant
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'est ce que je voulais je ne
sais plus je ma part de monsieur c'est
l'affolement
c'est marié qui n'est pas montré oui oui
oui mon mari vient mon mari monsieur
massenet dit venus aussi hier soir non
ça c'est fait j'ai un contrat je
m'intéresse pas d'être monsieur êtes
bien mal embouchées c'est vraiment la
mémoire ça vous fera dire le contraire
même soit raisonnable malaise ne serait
pas se mettre dans un état pareil c'est
du tarif des mains de quoi bien mais
madame ça c'est pas venir mais pas de
nouvelles bonnes nouvelles comme on dit
c'était bon signe que vous n'allez pas
me dire pour son brio cependant à ça
c'est la vérité va la tirer le contraire
mais je mentirais une voiture et conduit
monsieur peut-être eu deux dents et oui
on ne pouvait pas me suis tant ses
bagnoles
jan kohout téléphonie et vieux eh bien
rien ne donne rien non j'ai bien fait
tout ce que madame m'a dit d'abord la
tournée des restaurants tous fermés chez
maxime j'ai trouvé des garçons qui
balayait et impôts sharks ont balayé
s'était pas monsieur de là j'ai été
comme madame nadia la préfecture j'ai
fait ma déclaration au bureau des objets
perdus comme des objets perdus oui c'est
le même bureau aujourd'hui pour cause
d'économies du gouvernement on a réuni
les deux services comme c'est dans le
même ordre d'idée de la gta la mort
on n'y avait pas encore vu monsieur tong
mais on m'a dit qu'il fallait pas
désespérer qu'il était encore de bonheur
alors j'ai laissé le signalement de
monsieur taille ordinaires nées moyens
parlant couramment le français l'anglais
commerciaux à celle donnée également le
numéro de téléphone en cas qu'on aurait
la chance et bien merci beaumont us
c'est peut-être monsieur nono est là
chaque liste doit être monsieur belge en
doute nos très bien madame nous rien
manenti l'habilité qui dira le contraire
mais pourquoi tu tombes un pauvre ami
qu'est ce qu'ils trouvent pas à mon ami
je suis folle d'inquiétude vous me
pardonnerez de vous avoir téléphoné à
paris recommande aux yeux bleus ont
trouvé tellement désemparé il resta
tellement sale que j'ai éprouvé le
besoin de sentir un ami van hoye je ne
suis plus de 1000 à tête
comprenez mon mari mon mari n'est pas
montrée à 16h06 wizo si on m'avait
téléphone metge cette épouvante
mais voyons les prix mais qu'est ce qui
a bien pu lui arriver moody car en face
à ce n'est pas naturel gros on essaie
nuit jamais arrivé au nom des valeurs
vinci au loin valeurs comme vous y allez
un malheur n'arrive pas je ne fais pas
d'illusions quand on est des hommes que
diable tout n'est pas perdu et enquêtes
l'espoir n'a pas le droit de se laisser
abattre
il faut agir qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que je fasse je ne sais pas mais il faut
donner moi j'agis jamais à passer devant
le commissariat pour venir ici je suis
entouré le commissaire est un de mes
amis je lui ai dit mon cher plus en plus
ils font accompagner chez madame masse
mais qui a égaré son mari il m'a répondu
je vous suis il n'est pas le dire n'est
pas très fort parfois il est de la
police
il peut nous être en mesure dès qu'il
est mort il est permis de se mettre on
entendu tu as parfois mon ami je vous en
supplie que pour moi mais ça me fait mal
de vous voir pleurer comme ça ça fait
aussi mon ami sa fuite ont sophie vous
savez que je vous ai toujours aimé grave
et oui je vous ai aimés
je me suis toujours tu parce que vous
étiez marier mais puisque aujourd'hui je
puis parler
c'est horrible ce que vous dites plus
lent faire une déclaration hautement
pareil moi j'ai fait d'accord à ce
niveau il faut donc j'espère pour
supposer que j'écouterais favorablement
une déclaration non mais vous n'avez pas
pour nous c'est une façon de vous dire
que je vous étaient tous des mois et que
vous pouviez usé de moi comptez sur moi
abbas et sa saveur cette voie ça avance
ça voyez vous si tu étais trop mal
vis-à-vis de lui oh le pauvre chez romeu
il vous aimez pinera irait encore il me
disait ce brave gens s'il n'est pas
toujours très amusant mais c'est un bon
garçon y assurait pu penser lorsqu'il me
disais ça aujourd'hui
aulas a dit on le savait madame c'est
monsieur pleure tout le commissaire de
police roussillon
jéromine tous attendu comme le messie
proprement humaine qui messi
mais la messe n'est donc je vous ai
exposé les cruelles perplexité en effet
madame monsieur belge ans m'a mise au
courant croyez que je me félicite de
cette heureuse circonstance des vannes
pour nous autres commissaires une course
sensationnelle c'est une aubaine si
souvent avancement il faut bien dire
nous n'avons pas la part égale autre nom
j'ai des confrères à bell village sa
robe nude sont vraiment trop favorisés
qui sont des crimes madame biya casby
moi qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
fasse
nous avons un quartier déplorable vous
savez mon coude après la vaine
tournera-t-elle de mots côté monsieur
mas neuf personnalités honorablement
connus brusque disparition affaire
ténébreuse ça peut être superbe et les
aspies voulait à molène et préparez vous
à écrire voyons madame alors nous disons
que monsieur massenet aurait été
assassiné évidemment ceci leur eau de la
police les tabligh où vous n'auriez pas
par hasard un portrait de monsieur votre
mari vous n'ont mis qu'un à l'âge de
sept ans j'étais un peu jeune n'est ce
pas il a dû changé depuis
et ben si fâcheux très fâcheuses
passionnés d'ovalie squillaci 7 me suis
bien je suis dans un état de nervosité
je comprends madame on ne perd pas son
mari tous les jours
voulez-vous me permettre manade de vous
poser une question assez délicat est-ce
qu'il avait dévissé ce pauvre m il a
enfin été le joueur alcoolique et
automation ses deux mains c'est demain
c'est dommage le point de vue de notre
enquête
higuain 10e c'est madame c'est un maçon
masson qui rapporte les vêtements de
monsieur oui madame dit n'est trouvé
dans la rue qui fait moi monsieur les
messieurs ils l'étaient pas
c'est parce que tu as montant que j'ai
pu comprendre parce qu'à vrai dire ce
vin sont ils pas pensé
non c'est pas ça mais il aboie alors
forcément c'est un peu disloqué je pense
pourtant pas admettre qu'il se promène
tous avouent que ça se corse et ça se
corse car du métro lui un couteau
je viens mettez vous permet-il c'est un
mois font ces gens là je vais lui
demander justement justement c'est moi
c'est comme ça que ça m'intéresse en
souvienne je vous en prie madame vie ne
pas empiéter sur mes athlètes membres
avancé mon ami c'est vous alors qu'elle
avait trouvé les vêtements de monsieur
massenet dans larmes
c'est bien ce que vous lui demandez
madame eh bien vous voyez que je pouvais
faire aussi bien qu'il réponde est mon
ami
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi monsieur dan mais ça me
prend comme ça dans les moments
d'émotion
et puis
et puis c'est pas des [ __ ] et puis
sympa employés une bonne foi ce soit
fini non merci monsieur ça me vient
comme ça mais il va leur dire tout ce
que vous savez voilà je me rendais ce
matin mon chantier lorsque dans la rue
du colisée ne peux pas t'en numéro 21 ou
du colisée
j'ai trouvé ces vêtements que je
reconnus de varappe à retenir un certain
monsieur masse les 28 rue de longchamp
grâce aux papiers que renfermait le
portefeuille contenues dans les poches
et d'autres menus dont le portefeuille
vous y voilà une boîte à cash voilà une
bourse un trousseau de clés les
correspondances de minibus et la menue
monnaie
oui oui tout cela est bien à lui il a un
cure dent
c'est bête de mettre sa même la poche le
pardon est simple concept à venir toutes
les cartouches sont intactes ceci
tendrait à prouver que la victime a été
surprise puisque la passion se servir de
son arme et comment surtout est-il là
ses vêtements vous ne savez pas non non
tout ce que je sais moi si vous étiez là
il était sur le banc
oui et bien voilà sur le trottoir ce
n'est pas difficile vous veillez madame
lui dit ils ne seront pas obligés
d'employer cadence à naître ramon sacha
caisson avoir moi et les autres comme ça
vous êtes arrivé cette nuit lyon je
prends tu votes pour voir moi c'est de
naissance
c'est ma mère qui a été impressionné par
un lévrier qui lui était grimpée dessus
je comprends de sorte que vous seriez
nez de madame votre mère et deux seuls
évrier
[Musique]
justice
ou c'est vrai qu'elle était dans une
position intéressante elle a un jour est
la troisième j'ai compris c'est comme
qui dirait une envie l envers une envie
d'autres dans leur évasion vie voilà non
parce que nous sortons de la question il
s'agit de mon pauvre mari même je suis
bien obligé pourrait filer mes
recherches en vain c'est drôle ça et on
dort du servette - vous n'avez rien
trouvé aucun indice ce qu'il puisse nous
mettre sur la voie bon ben c'est bien
mon ami ray vous asseoir et là je vous
en supplie n'a boyer quo quand vous
interrogera
écrivez-nous commissaire de police et
cetera et cetera ayant été avisés de la
disparition mystérieuse de monsieur
masse mais la bouche à bouche et j'ai vu
la poser
c'est ça
vous êtes déjà levé mairie du bois oui
dis moi ça va bien il est en retard un
cador entretuent méchante mais pas
monsieur qu'est ce que vous voulez faire
et c'est mon mari est monsieur
enfin je suis heureuse et son mari sam
et rigole ça ne se fait pas ça monsieur
vous êtes disparus assassinés
la police est saisie on l'appellera de
revenir comme ça monsieur le commissaire
de police qui comprend pour as dit que
tu étais arrivé malheur mais ça on
ouvrait une enquête non c'est drôle
bah oui monsieur y'a plus qu'à la clore
votre enquête le permettez ça ne peut
pas se traduit comme ça le soit pas du
pantalon fait permettra se voyant plus
je veux la paix vous donne à faire des
plus sensationnelles
on n'a pas si souvent mais tout à
musique écoulée vous dites je regrette
mais puisque j'ai la chance d'être
encore de ce monde est ce qui arrive oui
oui non bien le savoir pourquoi tu as
par ailleurs et dans un tel accoutrement
commun dans un territoire marqué très
très louche
voilà
si j'ai gagné ma bougie
il commence à faire jouer à plein ce qui
fait le jeu merci et pas voilà à d'abord
j'aime autant te dire tout de suite ses
vêtements ne sont pas à moi alors je ne
prenais pas si c'est sûrement pourquoi
éviter bcb set face à un tube tu vas
comprendre voilà ce que j'étais dans le
look d'homme d'un trident l'inde en
train mais parce que tout ça c'est la
faute aux chemins de fer je m'étais
laissé aller à l'endormir sans penser
qu'il y avait des gens dans le
compartiment calais alors qu'est ce qui
est arrivé c'est que quand je me suis
réveillée envolées les gens ont volé mes
vêtements
ça sentait le chloroforme et j'étais
revenu mois de ceux de ce costume que tu
me vois c'est qu'il ne me va pas même si
trois corps auquel j'aimerais faire et
beige que le h tenait pas dit à moi je
ne vais pas te alors alors là tu vas
voir ça tient du prodige tels que tu me
vois j'arrive damien jayat bien c'est
vrai mon ami d'amérindiens vie parce que
je dois te dire que j'ai arrêté à la
gare accompagné deux amis à l'esp
restockage chez nous c'est quoi ces
demoiselles ou même que j'avais pris un
ticket dessous donnant accès sur le quai
et alors là sur le quai histoire de
poser
il me dit très gentiment mais monté don
dans le compartiment estimé me s vonews
cette façon là et alors est ce normal de
cette extraordinaire maintenant donc
dans les gares on ne donne plus signal
du départ
alors la locomotive s'est mise en marche
bêtement le train suivi
ce qu'est robert moi moi étant dans le
patois mais maintenant on est en une au
fond était d'une chose pas encore quand
tu sais j'ai eu de la chance à amiens on
a pu stopper pour faire de l'eau mais
sans ce besoin providentiel de la
machine au bourget j'avais jusqu'à
camorra mi moyens il a fallu revenir et
c'est précisément pendant le retour
comme les vêtements ont disparu
oui il y avait des gens je dormais ça
sentait le chloroforme à plein nez
comment savez vous savez c'est vous qui
me dit ah vous voyez alors là ça
concorde bien en main cities vous
entendez vous avez souvent tard en héros
mais croit rien cet homme là évidemment
c'est très palpitant est plutôt vous
demander monsieur monsieur le guen
mistler étant donné que nous vous
dépouiller du revêtement compariez on a
pu retrouver les 10 vêtements sur le
trottoir de la rue du colisée opus est
cocasse c'est vrai monsieur si on le
sait on n'est pas fait mentir le
parfaite ça vous la coupe ça me n'est
pas vide on expliqué ouais c'est
pourquoi l'ex entraîneur la saint
patrick dumas - ça coule de source
je pense était dans le train il marche
vite à il est en marche et même très
vite j'ai rarement vu un train marché
aux civils
lorsque tout à coup les specs qui met ce
thème avant que ça peut-être commençait
à m'agacer la noémie pas colombie c'est
vrai ça il est la marque du côté emile
emile est ce que je sais comment mes
vêtements sont allés jouer vu du colisée
c'est vrai ça j'étais pâmé que l étude
annonce et puis d'abord du temps qu'est
ce qui les a trouvés mais 26 cet homme
c'est vous
est-ce que j'étais avec le haut à
l'écouté
elle vous demande pas de faire le sien
je vous demande si j'étais avec eux
[Applaudissements]
non ah non pardon ne s'était pas avec
quoi on n'est plus ensemble on n'est pas
responsable il ya des jours mais
qu'est-ce qu'il vous dise monsieur vous
êtes de la police
c'est votre avis comment dont vous
croyez pas si bien dire j paul une
affaire que nous soient instruits
ressentons ça vous intéresse pas du
moment qu'on a retrouvé des vêtements
voulez vous laisser sa peau et vous
regarde pas non plus une chauffe des
essais mais qu est ce qu est l aime
pêcher ce commissaire la rabaisser mois
une ménages se félicite tu peux leur
apporter où tu l'as pris vous dites je
parle à monsieur d'image vous parlez je
vous dis que vous reconnu dans une
lettre s équivoque
et puis les mâles massot et pour
commencer vous avez vous deviné à notre
disposition il n'y a plus d'amis vient
de magistrats qui ne suis mauvais
nom d'un chien soir hommage ferry
monsieur n'a plus besoin de maintenant
si apporter moi mon vêtements
d'intérieur et vos marteaux du thé bien
chaud est deuxième avec du rock à sa
place ou santé enfin tranquille chez soi
a suivi nous y attachons donc être pas
les commandes parce que j'ai une
traversée à nous rencontrer
il me semble que sartre enfin nous
conservons mieux son bonheur après petit
peu plus mon père et de son mari pour
comprendre combien aux lèvres m'a pas
dit on c'est pas bon marché ça ne
m'étonne monsieur la pression bon c'est
ça oui monsieur
jamais les fans oui madame
oui oui oui comment a parfaitement oui
qu'est ce que c'est c'est de la mort que
monsieur comment demander un pays comme
en quoi qu'est ce que vous dites comment
on a repêché qu'est-ce qu'on empêchait
c'est pour avertir qu on a repêché une
part de monsieur au bâton mieux comment
leur coach et d'un temps quoi dans un
état de décomposition avancée chez riot
pas regardez moi ça va plutôt qu'on
maîtrise il faut répondre a dit que
c'est parce qu'ils sont fous oui dès qu
elle voulait que vous êtes à vieillir
alors oui monsieur monde domestique
monique comme annoncé a tellement pas
monsieur c'est lui même qui vous parle
vous dit si vous pouvez en disposer
mais je vous en prie monsieur disposer
disposer
vous pouvez même changer de tiroir non
non non non il n'ya pas de mal
pas du tout vous êtes très aimable d'en
voir monsieur fau ils sont trés
obligeant à la morgue qui disent tout à
votre service à une autre occasion un
livre a dû perdre un certain ivan cupic
sur moi puisque vous n'avez pas
m'appeler pour non mais c'est vrai je
dirais le contraire je mentionnais non
ça va pas recommencer à produire et
madame introduit dans l'appartement un
livre à mes yeux mais elle est venue
avec moi et puis donc à passer devant
j'ai toujours des engagements souscrits
via et compte même en tirer
oh c'est heureux les femmes
en audit et en du tcs c'est gentil diem
la pensée à après nuit dont une tasse de
thé serre note aaa
ça va nous faire du bien
non non jamais dessus de remonter car ça
c'est bon ça
il est bien un fusée
c'est un peu le point via le président à
la honda alors vous vous allez faire le
plaisir de fiches le corps et évite tout
juste à sortir pas mon domaine seront
émises il ya pas d oui au moment ne me
connaissez comme enfant mon dieu mon
dieu je t'écoute non écoute non écoute
je voudrais te pose une question rien du
tout une question et je parle je suis
vous blini pourquoi as tu pris vertement
moi j'ai pris mauvais alors les mecs pas
que monsieur avec certaines y aller
pourquoi pour les prix viennent tam hier
mais maintenant ça recommence on sait ce
que j'en fais c'est pas pour moi c'est
gaby thématique une heure at war
quelqu'un te retrouves était maintenant
eh ben on va vous en faire de l' un des
vêtements les conditions c'est vous
fichez le camp après ces jurés gérer le
côté alors bon ma femme au madame madame
vous croyez bien que ri c'est vous
taisez vous mais à quoi je fais et vous
mais dis moi qui est sympa mais c'est
fou je suis avec mon chapeau et mon
par-dessus fois dans un salon s'est pas
faite au règlement
voulez vous garder ça risque de tourner
convenance avant tout il a livré un
petit penchant pour les mois pas le
temps vestiaires vous l'avez par honte
devant ma femme couche est un fin
mélange madame non mais t'as faim tu me
l'as déjà présentés cette saison
ou alors t'es bigard ne sais pas
pourquoi tu nous présenter ta femme
cette nuit même sais pas pourquoi toutes
les stupidités que j'aime dans le
cerveau de ces prochains jours est hissé
seul marqué par antiphrase les poivrots
ou ne rougissez pas d'autres turpitudes
du châtillonnais de la légal team
étoiles comme 900 elle a mené la maison
parce que dans cette histoire qui ne
restent pas l'acheter free g20 est piégé
choix fin de rang 10e d'abord puisque la
diplomatie ne sert à rien autant pour
été les grands moyens elle alors là vous
allez voir ce que vous allez voir vous
ne vous mais je pourrais jamais il est
trop lourd alors prenez le sous les bras
et moi sont des images bien essayé mais
jamais
ça va très bien il pèse rien ah bah
peut-être sous les genoux mais pas sous
les aisselles
il faut appeler au moins 100 kg lanoraie
108 monsieur je vais l'acheter
allez si bien cecily les montagnes ne
s'est pas terminée mais tu crois qu'il
sait faire ce gros tapis vert sombre
bras du sien dans six jeux suivants de
permettre aux sinistrés port le
brandissent haddad notion est servi dans
leur vie celle à moussa koussa membres
du ch mari si monsieur martin brody owen
et voilà maintenant à vis de
l'empressement et fait reculer par
l'escalier de service telles nouvelles
tuiles en cours alors assez comme ça
c'est pas sûr que nous y
ah si si si je suis bien à toi j'te
parle à moi oui c'était rien
non pardon je suis un peu mon ami j'ai
besoin de toi je me bats toi vous oui je
ne peux pas encore vous dire pourquoi
plus tard peut-être si le scandale
éclate au mec jusque là c'est un hobby
bertin libertin c'est hubert tu le
connais s'est encore tassée la première
phase d'une tendance non là parce qu'un
joli mot chapeau casting et j'ai réussi
à l'habiller à bravo il m'a dit son nom
il s'appelle l'hubertin quoi qu'est ce
qu'il a dit bertail la vie vertueux non
il n'a pas d'un ferry ce n'est pas une
liberté
dans l'assiette bon vieux nom de chiens
les chats n'a donc voilà je vais
t'expliquer voilà des gens qui font que
je reçoive un statut des personnes avec
qui j'ai rendez vous veux-tu accompagné
contre lui par là le temps de les
expliquer je suis un 3e but en premier
league ce soir chéri c'est ça c'est ça
c'est ça
mais alors toi faiblit pas aucune
journée mon dieu je te dérange du tout
du tas entre francine
afin de la franchise si je n'étais pas
là tu l'appellerai france il est bien de
gènes dans quoi pour moi j'écoutais mon
chien je comprends votre ironise
françois fourment vouliez et je suis
louette en vouloir et pourquoi mon dieu
ah parce que de ma femme et toi
vaugoyeau voilà une affaire qu'est-ce
que ça prouve que ma femme tu as plus eh
ben mon vieux pourquoi n'aurait-elle pas
plus elle m'a bien plu hamoir ce diplômé
tounes
il faut être philosophe surtout devant
ce qu'on ne peut pas empêcher qu'un
assieds toi ma chérie époux concert je
ne sais pas mais tu me s'occuper dans
l'ès dos argenté du parc sur le mot
vendable oui j'ai vu rouge quand j'ai
entendu le photographe vous auriez été
là je n'aurais pu tous les deux
seulement vous n'y étiez pas vous mais
vous aurez que c'était difficile à
exécuter en votre absence
alors ma foi ça m'a permis de réfléchir
je me suis dit mon vieux tu l'aies par
mona dans l'essai il faut savoir appeler
les choses par leur nom
ça y est tout ce que tu diras ou rien
donc le mieux est de faire contre
mauvaise fortune bon coeur
au fond ces enfants n'ont pas fait ça
pour ton pétrole non et je le sais bien
mais pauvre petit tient les assieds toi
dans ta vie mais alors si vous ne l'avez
pas fait pour m'embêter c'est donc que
vous vous aimez et j'irai moi me mettre
en travers pour vous en empêcher allons
donc sanaa alors voici ce que j'ai
décidé je fais constaté le flagrant
délit
ça c'est entendu parce qu'enfin j'ai ma
situation régularisée trop juste mais
tout ça sans bruit sans trompette pas
d'éclat un petit flagrant délit de rien
du tout tout ce qu'il ya de plus
modestes le flagrant délit d pauvreté ça
de façon à ce que ça passe tout à fait
inaperçu
on retiendra le nom de francine parce
qu'il n'y a pas moyen de faire autrement
mais le tien ne sera pas prononcée on
poursuivra contre inconnu chanal contre
3 étoiles mon ami tu es d'une délicate à
nouveau à lyon
ça dépend parce que j'ai éprouvé un
déboire conjugale que je vais subir à
deville sentiment de représailles et
basa serait d'une jolie peinture
non non il ne s'agit plus de moi
maintenant il s'agit de toi il s'agit de
ton bonheur
il s'agit de celui de tafas on y pense
même à ma femme
j'irai brisé l'avenir de deux êtres qui
ont tout pour être heureux jamais
j'écoute mon ami dès que les sublimes
il est sublime sublime nord vont être
comme ça j'estime que le mariage comme
une partie de bakara tant que vous avez
la veine vous garder la main après une
série plus ou moins heureuses arrive à
monsieur peu plus veinards qui prend les
cartes contre vous il gagne le coup la
main passe et bien c'est ainsi que
j'entends qu'il en soit j'ai perdu le
coup il y à une suite à toi les cas là
ma part dans ma prof quelles mains et
celle de ma femme noire bleue elle est à
toi je te la donne un débat oui puisque
tu lé pou moi moi moi épouse est affamé
jamais jamais david ans mais tu
plaisantes pourquoi ça et est ce que je
peux je suis marqué moi tu es marié
mesdames radio que c'est embêtant ça aa
ans est en détention et âme sans sarah
tu es marié oui vous pouvez violer un
jeune diplômé qu'est ce que tu veux que
sa main sera donc ça ne me regarde pas
qui était bien marié déjà quand avec
trois femmes pas tant pis pour toi
fallait y réfléchir avant et les fortes
lorsque tout de même pas devenir
guillaume est bien mais divers mais
c'est fou non mais il est fou mais c'est
pour enfin voyons en droit vous savez
je ne connais qu'une chose quand un
homme a été la cause de divorce d'une
femme marié et lui doit de l'épouser
mais même si je le voulais que ma femme
qu'est ce que tu veux je lui disais tu
n'as qu'à lui dire ce qui s'est passé je
t'assure que ça arrangera tout à non non
et c'est sa jane veux tu que je m'en
charge non merci non enfin bon la mia
pas il faut choisir où tu épouses ou
alors tant pis pour toi je t'ai penser
les tribunaux c'est touchant pas c'est
tout ce que tu voudras mais il faut
choisi les fous de dieu qu'est-ce que
c'est ce sont les commissionnaires avec
dix mâles ont commandé même avis je sais
mais qu'ils offrent
ce sont les mâles de ma femme comment
l'as tu vois on apporte de ces mannes
selon des sites travail auquel champ
communal mais n'est jamais trahi les
chambres mais vous me portez sa petite
ne l'écouté pas mais moi je me suis
comporté salle à la pause et ce à la mer
si beau d'aller à les présents mais amer
mais tu suces anna rocard dont le sport
ne connaît pas ça ne me tue ma femme
chanal ma femme la femme manal c'est pas
des mâles c'est pas des masses à 6,1
célébrer ce sont les mâles de ma femme
non d'un chien c'est marrant ce qu'est
ce qui se passe c'est très peu de chose
est cassé
alors allons-y voilà c'est mon ami sean
lamont vieillesse pénale au mon vieux
[ __ ] et alors il est venu passer
quelques temps à paris avec ces
malheureux
qu'est ce que tu racontes si mais si m
mais moi je pourrais tu l'emmènes voici
les voilà aujourd'hui
écoutez
vaudreuil au député élu du peuple tel
mais c'est pire qu'à la chambre basse
yeux pleins de vie à faire me suis
passionné vous êtes bloqué deux mois
tout voyage qu elle n est qu une
balançoire pour visiter pas les miens
c'est au prix s'est tenue ridiculiser en
flagrant délit d'adultère avec l'époux
d'un monsieur chanal 1,8 et bah oui quoi
mais tout le monde le sait tu étais
surpris toi j'avais de moi ni colère ni
violence tout est fini entre nous c'est
officiel enfin voyons et l'amant c'était
vous ouais tiens on met plus
époustouflant au bourg sera nick et moi
même mais vous les miens et patrouilles
tout s'arrange
mais
qu'est ce qu'elle fait là celle-là c'est
pour sa place à la la la la
c'est monsieur qu'a sonné oui c'est moi
vous êtes bien sûr que madame noir en
très bon sur monsieur pour des années
d'ailleurs madame m'a bien recommandé
pour monsieur
elle m'a dit monsieur mon ancien marche
doit venir vers 1h vous le ferez à temps
vous le ferez attendre où je le ferais
attendre vous le ferez attendre deux
heures et quart je venais pourtant dit
j'ai cru que je viendrais à une heure en
arrivant à une heure et demie j'ai des
chances que et bien non on ne peut pas
être en retard avec madame je trouve
encore moyenne posé trois quarts d'heure
monsieur c'est même du temps de monsieur
madame pour l'heure aux sexes aspirer
plus d'une fois monsieur qui mois non
monsieur actuelle
ah oui l'europe et bien je ne suis pas
fâché qu'un autre vois pas ce que c'est
mais qu'est ce qu'il fait ici ce
fauteuil les du petit salon en a c'est
madame qui l'a mis là tu es drôle cette
manie de ne jamais laisser les choses à
leur place et est pas le sien
à part ça ça va ici mais comme ça
monsieur
j'ai ma femme qui m'a donné un garçon
ont chanté non je parlais de madame
formol monsieur pas m'emballer
eh bah tant mieux je peux dire qu'elle a
une grossesse très dur qui ma femme ah
oui pardon à nos sens qui est venue
avant terme pensez à cinq mois
vraiment mon pauvre etienne tant de
souffrances pour rien on pour rien mais
il est superbe
monsieur il pesé 11 livres augmente au
monde assad mois ou et monsieur à c'est
un pas très rare le médecin a même dit
que c'est très heureux qu'ils soient
liés à cette époque
sinon on n'aurait pas pu la voir il
aurait été trop gros voyons à cinq mois
vous devez vous trompez de cible
monsieur les dates sont là ma femme a
été pendant dix mois dans lui dit et
elle n'est revenue qu'il y a 6 mois
ainsi en effet alors là elle était chez
ses maîtres à montpellier alors oui si
elle était chez sa mère mais qu'est ce
qu'ils font c'est m il est officier de
l'armée
oui
il me ressemble beaucoup l'officier des
noms le petit à l'appeler livigno un peu
c'est bien ça et c'est une attention car
enfin à rien évidemment au monsieur est
bien votre s'intéresser à moi vous savez
en attendant madame justement grâce à
mon cher je vous demande pardon
michel germain a fortement l'enfant
toutefois sur un plateau je mange des
lionnes mon pauvre ami j'attends je vous
fais toutes mes excuses il ya longtemps
que vous êtes là trois quarts de mon
mieux je criais nous avoir fait
attention
non si vous avez mal choisi votre jour
votre lettre m'est arrivé ce matin est
juste j'avais deux essais gages et un
enterrement que je n'ai pas pu remettre
volontairement sur le goût du lait du
show mais vous savez au tout selon pas
tous d'être gourmand à mon ami ça me
fait plaisir à voir
moi aussi on a beau dire voyez vous
quand on a été marié fois mais bon ça
crée des liens
comment sait centrer mais indissoluble
la loi voléro la nature et la
technologie
au fond il n'y a que le premier mari qui
grattent taisez-vous si mon mari vous
entamez s'il m'entendait je lui dirais
pas la preuve qu'il reste toujours
quelque chose c'est que je suis ici pour
ces titres que nous n'avons pu négocier
au moment du divorce
c'est pas moi que regus et m'ont avoué
je pas pu résister il y a trois jours je
suis à paris je me suis dit il faut que
j'en profite pour aller les voir un
banal si revoir celles qui fument à
faire mais la revoir en bon camarade un
petit vieux fait toujours aussi gentil
toi et fais ce que tu veux l'habitude
souhaite mais alors il faudrait
peut-être demandé à mme ashton est pour
lui s'il n'est pas content est ce qu'il
t'a demandé la permission à toi
autrefois pour wilson c'était beaucoup
plus grosse salle est très bon à la
voiture a mille fois raison tutoyons à
mon pauvre chérie je dois bien qu'ils
n'étaient pas demandé la permission
alors parce que tu aurais dit non et
villas boas évidemment ce sera encore ta
femme alors qu'il est méritée face tout
apprécié voiture si les maris pouvait
laisser leurs femmes avoir un ou deux
amants pour leur permettre de comparer
il y aurait beaucoup plus de femmes
fidèles
je serai là ça gerald à la hausse à
voyons mais ça nous allons boys love
c'est pas drôle tous les jours voilà
maintenant supporter tout le temps des
scènes lui qui était si l'art jeudi des
camps c'était toi qui était en jeu il
faut le voir maintenant qu'il y ait pour
son compte
ombrageux jaloux voyant le mal dans tout
et sans réseau naturellement comme
toujours car vois je ne me trompe pas je
lui suis fidèle je te le dire n est ce
pas je ne me gênerai pas avec toi merci
il est prête à voxan ici il ne reçoit
plus un ami parce que c'est des hommes
comme s'il savait jamais empêché quelque
chose quand une femme a ça dans la tête
tout au plus court tout nu parce qu'elle
n'est pas dans nos oreilles monts kunlun
uil après s'être fassions ensemble ils
se sont réconciliés à l'occasion de mon
mariage
et comme coustous une bafouille plus que
jamais il est tranquille mais je
t'assure comme distraction
alors ça ne va pas bah dis donc tu dis
ça comme si ça faisait plaisir aux ip au
fond pourquoi mentir évidemment je suis
chagriné pourquoi mais à côté de ça je
serais très vite si tu venais me dire à
mon ami comme je suis beaucoup plus
heureuse que de tonton gistel est un
homme a très bien et ya été déposées çà
sur la petite table et ben alors est
elle donc oui on va chez moi l'habitude
de la voir là toujours magnin et y est
loin de monsieur monsieur attendu madame
pour se mettre à table mais comme haram
n'est pas monsieur a pris son chapeau
une partie sans déjeuner en disant nous
allons un peu voir ce que ça signifie
monsieur n'avait pas l'air con vu passer
bien c'est bien et est à nous avait vu
monsieur oui bien sûr lorsque nous avons
été heureux de savoir monsieur la merci
et aime et qui nous mais nous monsieur
mois et la cuisinière
tu as toujours cette bonne madeleine
jour elle serait si content si elle
pouvait voir monsieur but elles viennent
enfin tu fermes et madeleine
en prime à bonn madeleine on monsieur
être au fond il ne me suis pas toujours
bien et comme vous voyez madeleine et
vous ça va monsieur adam c'est pas comme
tu tombes monsieur on sait pas que
monsieur soit pas un bon mètre mais
c'est égal c'est quand même pas monsieur
il est pas attentionné comme monsieur
avec les domestiques à monsieur était
beaucoup plus gratin ouais
un stade c'est vrai non vous voulez dire
que je vous gâte est davantage au oui
c'est bien madame c'est bien maintenant
vous avez vu monsieur allez dans votre
cuisine et dit damaris variés sortie
modère le relais dans ma chambre et
apportez moi ici maroc tigana j'ai hâte
de quitter cette robe pour chose enfin
apporter mois revient à 3-2 sur un
plateau etienne viable j'ai pas encore
déjeuner mois alors qu'il est et bien va
se laisser comme ça tombe des bons jeux
aucun journal je ne sais pas si c'était
un si long temps mon cher le voit
laquelle on peut se mettre à table avec
madonna 1 80 m à table sans moi on n'est
pas marie pour prendre ses repas chacun
son contrat tout aussi fermes et et
lagacé longtemps je suis rentré cette
fouille à 15h le conscience maladie tue
un tirage à cause qui ont combattu et
paix dans le monde au concert aussi aux
hommes et enfants
vous n'allez pas choisir le jour où je
viens pour vous dire soisy pas que tu
croire même bien national on peut être
que c'est amer et ben c'est fou parce
que je reviens moi c'est amer j'ai voulu
en avoir le coeur net
eh ben tu ne l'a pas été depuis samedi
dernier la saq est sorti tout veut aussi
dire assez c'est toi te ferais remarquer
que j'ai déjeuné tous les jours ici et
comme j'ai pour habitude elle n'est
jamais qu'une fois que l'on s'attarde
sur la plateau qui m'attend si tu aimes
pris la peine de regarder avant de
parler
on voit que c'est possible des zones you
fat et jeunesse importe peu en espèces
tout ça ne me dit pas ce que tu peux
faire dehors tous les jours jusqu'à des
heures ce même enfant elle a donc je
devrais chemla mollahs est tous contents
on commence à le croire quoi après tout
ce ne sera pas le premier
qu'est ce que tu dis parfaitement moi
j'ai des amants oui toi ki nam en arrive
à moi c'est lui qui me reprochent
nos petits thons etienne quand vous
aurez fini de valser cause et ça l'a
enfin et bien été bien j'y ai mis du sel
du poivre 23 bis et autres mon dieu
c'est pas de prof je dis qu'est ce que
tu as fait avec moi j'avais pu faire
avec tout ça va tu l'antarès le long feu
comment peux tu as tu lu ma récompense
de tout ce que je fais pour lui
quand je pense que j'étais la femme la
nonette hommes et que pour cet être là
j'ai foulé aux pieds le bonheur de cette
année pas après trompait parfaitement
trompé on écoute et si on ne parlait pas
de moi et parce que je t'aime tu m'aimes
même si je t'aime elle même est raide
mais que je n'aime pas cette
conversation
malheureusement ce thème à chaque faille
assez cher aujourd'hui le grand tort que
nous avons aux autres femmes c'est pour
amant le cherchait toujours à l'homme
que nous aimons alors que la vérité sur
l associant qui nous aiment ou de
n'embaucher que ce n'est pas toi je n'y
sois dire c'est costaud du costume
lui-même n est ce pas qui seront j'ai
pour moi lui et qu'il n'aurait jamais
reprocher et violent jamais jamais
jamais jamais nous devons faire c'est on
court tous deux militent encore là tu
sais qu'il peut avant d'être finalement
tête que je prendrais tu ce
véritablement mon ami tu fous là je le
range re en forme de cornet sensation
aux règles d'une femme qu'elle entend
apparemment il arrive qu'elle finit par
se familiariser avec cette idée et trois
gardes
quand une femme a ça dans la tête et
puis ton quand elle a ça dans le sang
c'est pour moi tu lis ça oui c'est pour
toi mais c'est pour toi courtisane au
voilà c'est quoi non je ne permettrai
porte on parle la main à nana à ta femme
comme ça devant moi
écoute mon petit temps quelle a été ta
femme et qu'elle a eu des amants je ne
m'en suis pas mêlé comment déjà mort ni
carte gold s'est imposé mon ménage comme
je l'entends voyons mes enfants je vous
en supplie manger votre viande là tant
qu'elle est froide
c'est vrai ça fait pas qu'on me serais
rendu malade une bonne occasion de dire
que c'est ma faute c'est pas maintenant
mes enfants mes enfants quand on pense
que la vie est si courte et vous vous la
gâcher le plaisir et tout ça pour rien
pour rien beauregard si vous pouviez
prendre l'habitude de vous expliquer
simplement au lieu de partir tout de
suite en guerre au mes à commencer par
toi si t'es lui avait demandé simplement
voiture était au pardon
kddi ntt tandis que c'était lui avais
dit où as tu été ma chérie pour rentrer
déjeuner à 3 heures de l'après midi et
aurait répondu moshiri vin comme deux
amours le j'ai été un enterrement des du
chômage alors que l'amendé du show mais
les dames c'était aujourd'hui mais oui
bah tu vois alors lève toi comment les
voyons aller et maintenant vous allez
faire la paix veux-tu bien aléatoire
alors voyons des gens très bien un jour
ou l'autre le jouer avec lui et finit à
la halle et embrassez vous qu'athènes
aura poussé à quelques coups de tête il
sera bien avancé mais maintenant je suis
prévenu j'aurai le tabac layton tous les
maris n'y a qu'à voir quand ça arrive
c'est toujours celui là qui soupçonne le
mois n'est ce pas le site honorait côté
les gens bougent en supplie laissez moi
au delà lalalalalalalalala oui à la la
la la la la d20 casque à madeleine si la
comédie mais bien comment ça tu as rome
contre un tablier dans le salon je
suppose mais pourquoi il ya personne qui
a précédemment et lui mais lui il
connaît
les jeunes quote-part comme quoi tu ne
comptes pas monsieur était assez
longtemps le mari à la maison mais tout
de ce qui est mon cas ça n'a aucune
importance c'est très bien dit dans des
jaloux de moi or pas du tout seulement
dans le salon non
vous dérangez pas pourquoi et à part ça
m'en sers chanal un poids de 9 mais rien
il ya longtemps qu'on sait pas
oh non mais bien en avril bof si ça fait
un an à naturel mourir et oui
naturellement nous récoltons supplie
laisse mater tranquille
non mais c'est vrai c'est s'il vous
plaindre à fait moi madeleine c'est que
j'ai un peu peur madame et les doigts
d'une cuisinière mais si monsieur
voulait annonce pas toi alors pas lui
être maladroit mer salle si tu veux tu
si le top on voit les volontés chaque où
il maintenant aucune pudeur
non mais l'eau est savamment voilà
bientôt la buvette s'accrocher moi ton
cas voilà et puis vous allez vous aurez
quand je ne vous voit plus on va voir
cette maison pour ça c'est possible mais
je t'ai épousée et tu me regardes ne
pousse pas vos marques à partir de là
c'est tu entends en mer assez assez
assez assez
voyons au belge laurens mon ami or en
fin match mais je trouve qu'on cherchait
à me recevoir mais ça ne respire en
point compte que ta femme et j'en ai
assez fois que j'en ai par dessus la
terre elle va justement il s'agit de
taba tant mieux et occupa de matt est en
vive à paris pour mon ami en mon ami tu
m'apparaît pas comme le rayon de soleil
or qu'est-ce que tu es devenu depuis un
an
mathieu assez lâches et quand tu sues
dont la vie est la première fois que tu
la vois toujours qu'est ce que devient
pas oui madame merkel à laquelle vous
laisse j'ai fait de la quitter nous
étions si heureux enfin le passé est le
passé
alors quoi qu'est ce qui t'amène et ben
voila moi je venais à l'envié que j'ai
l'intention de me marier auront la vie
prend un verre tu ne sais pas quel
danger tout explose si tu tombe mal
regarde-moi fin mai mais moi je me donne
pas mal le dit toujours ça avant il
compte une fois c'est fait cette
collecte seulement bien la femme que tu
es fou oui si je te croit benoît après
cette affaire
ouais c'est sophie ta première femme n'a
pas même pas où il allait si mal et vous
m'en fiche ça m'est égal
vous êtes libre je sais bien sots si
sophie qui a tenu absolument à ce que si
un traitement des tons consentement
consentement non merkel perd la tête
qu'est-ce que je suis son père est ce
que je suis sa mère est ce que ça ne
regarde pas voilà c'est ce que je lui ai
dit ça passe et sa condition sinequanone
sinequa comptines et quoiqu'on tout
sauter d'or mais du moment qu'elle met
plus à toi que ce soit moi ou un autre
on n'en sait rien je te donnerai un
certificat ans et ça je vais lui dire ça
tout de suite justement elle met en
avant dans ce but ultime et marinette
embarras aux épouses peut obliger ce
serait gentil ça coûte ça c'est tout à
fin juillet oui quand elle sera là sans
avoir l'air de rien mais je suis tu
pouvais un peu me faire valoir oui citer
mes qualités au oui j'en ai tout c'est
horrible
le caire et aux latéraux stone je
comprends ce sont des choses que je ne
peux pas faire moi-même et délicate a
dit que venant de toi serait tout de
suite un pouvoir bien je fais valoir la
marche encore sélectionné oui téléphonez
au concierge ou il déplie en bas une
dame dans une voiture et il a pris de la
part de monsieur belle chance d'avoir la
présence de monter très bien merci la
vienne non
à vaux rien que le mot qu'est ce qui
t'arrive et bien voilà je mets je venais
alors pardon monsieur shana l'ancien
mari de ma femme
monsieur monsieur belge en son futur
mari de la mienne je vous félicite mais
moins de même peu de choses je suis là
tout seul et pas pour un journal lee oui
c'est ce que je fais mais quand je dis
j'aime bien fait mais tu n'as pas
quelque chose dont j'ai oublié mes
cigarettes tu sais bien que je ne fume
pas voyons un temps il doit rester
quelques cigares par là mais même qui
viennent de toi on va parfait merci ne
vous dérangez pas monsieur tous mes
voeux tous mes compliments raisons tu
sais moi je suis profondément touché à
monsieur monsieur je me sens bien
l'effort quand tu t'imposes pour de
rendre service à la fin tu veux toujours
à sophie si si si si je sors et peu
salée ça n'est pas juste je peux tous
affichent une chose c'est que bien des
fois devant moi elle a regretté d'avoir
été aussi intransigeant un coin à huy à
bien des fois c'est vraiment un bébé
s'en fout c'est bon de concierge d'abord
pourquoi avoir fait ce que vous avez
fait pourquoi avoir été ainsi inflexible
pourquoi mais pourquoi qu'enfin tant que
vérité quand de rigueur tant de rigueur
pour une folie d'un moment pour rien et
ça sans vous demander si je n'allais pas
être très malheureux et enfin vous le
saviez que je vous aime et aux mille et
oui je vous avais oui je t'aimais je
suis la mort tu m'aimais mais pas assez
pour empêcher de chercher des diversions
à y aller quel que soient vos goûts
c'est naturellement ça pour vous autres
soirs ça ne compte jamais rien mais moi
moi je t'aimais aux racines profondément
puisque toi suite en guérir loi
bienvenue puisque ça ne t'empêche pas
d'épouser belge en rafale alors étudiant
à la fois raison ça prouve médaille on
le sait très bien
j'ai beaucoup d'affection pour lui mais
je ne la connais pas alors tu n'as pas
le droit que les plus jeunes comment
commence à la porte ou non non non il
n'a pas le droit de dire c'est pas pour
lui dire ça que je t'ai pris cette
affaire monte et ça m'est égal en ce
moment c'est ton bonheur quand j'étais
forte à peu de charbon bonheur
parfaitement ton bonheur et c'est même
une fois que cette conversation a lieu
maintenant ça nous a permis de voir que
nous nous aimions toujours au oui nous
nous aimons et cusset quant aux êtres
s'aiment fatalement un jour les rejette
dans les bras l'un de l'autre et
pouvons-nous faire cette peine un ami
comme toi mais non mais les locaux n'ont
peut-être pas que toi évidemment tu vas
être très malheureux au sahara mais
william et melle nous te devons ça
sa voix très malheureux une bonne foi
tout de suite que tu exposes elle
devenir plus tard enfin mes parents il
s'agirait que je me sacrifier pour ton
bonheur ce serait avec plaisir mais nous
n'avons pas le droit de penser qu'elle
nous nous devons penser qu'elle a moi
moi elle nous n'avons pas le droit
d'être égoïste n'est ce pas masos et
pourquoi lady pas livré les jeunes frais
libre je t'aime tu m'aimes je divorce et
nous nous marions nous aviez dit nora
jean monnet léon mbou il en est d'autant
plus que personne ne t'a demandé tenir
voici gérer chine ça va vous soupçonnez
pas ce caractère autoritaire jalons
euros alors qu'il aimait ce cas qui
démontre tout à l'heure je me
sacrifierai pour son bonheur
il s'agit du nom moi tu voyais temps de
qualité et bien je suis heureuse d'avoir
appris à me connaître
alors je vous prie de bien vouloir
m'excuser sa fille à bientôt
j'avoue produisit moi je peux tout de
même on me oui voyons vous êtes toujours
notre part on renvoie l'emportons nous
allons kessany retraites s'annonce à la
fois à mon ami jacques antoine l'homme
éperdument amoureux frappe de france et
les français
qu'est ce que tu me sens vraiment de
sophie de ma première femme d'un
français ou seulement des prévenus c'est
toi qui leur a volé ou ex collègue
refrain du programme
et bien pour le sait puisque pour meurt
dans vie devant lui et que je te pince
c'est tout ce que tu es dans la table à
dire deux fois qu'on l'avait si vos
revenus vous on ne défie pas une famille
l'imbécile imbéciles à ce contenu
à tous tout c'est le ciel qui la dame je
laissais pas venez vous je vous parlais
à bois pas et c'est quoi fumer mais
n'est-ce par mois au nom au non non non
non non non non non non
oui non non je fais bien je suis à vous
fait de moi ce qu'il vous plaira quoi
qu'est ce que vous y allez allez profite
essentiellement mon psychologue a calé à
étudier alors vous n'allez pas vous
évanouir c'est pas le moment embrassés
mais en quoi offre aussi aux enjeux
principaux des trous et je te disais
tout à l'heure on ne défie pas une fan
on a fini par parler de la femme seule
la france pouvait divorcer on va du
train où vont les choses soient du train
15.4 a pas plus tard qu il y a deux
minutes tu as femmes là avec costco
youssou ndour qu'est ce que tu me semble
parfaitement il est ramené dans ses bras
il la couvre ac baiser or au tuc ferry
aux mairies ri et nous verrons bien le
bâtonnier ci soit ea qu'est ce que je
cherche le divorce ça fera le bonheur de
tout le monde et moi j'aurais pour ma
femme qui n'en a pas le droit avis
pourquoi on ne peut pas épousé sa
première femme d'éléments de la
secondera c'est la loi il ya la loi de
la nature et des moussons dépouille
légitimement choisis tu as fait tout ce
qu'il fallait pour ça tu ne rentres pas
le cas toi même
demain tu attends demain ce sera chose
accord passé de mains en or de via les
modes de preuve
évidemment tu éloquent pan-allemand on
est suicidé il ya 70 ans l'exacte vérité
ne s'est pas fait et qu'elle celui qui
est une pensée même pas je vais l'être
le dîner par le vendeur parbleu c'est
bien ça c'est costaud you je te dit tout
et bonjour mon cher matinée comment ça
va aujourd'hui qu'elle tend un soleil
radieux
je passais sous ses fenêtres je me suis
dit je vais monter lui serrer la main tu
a bonne mine tu sais c'est vrai il au
chan alors revenant alors mais il parle
mais tu pars au boeuf
voilà vous sur madame je vous garde et
pour la bonne bouche la dernière vous
allez bien fait attention voyons vous ne
bafouille et depuis à la chaire mama
mama snecma massonnet voici ce qui
m'amène je voudrais te faire part d'une
idée que j'ai eue et savoir si elle t'a
grennan on voit donc voilà avez vous
remarqué et amis comme nous le sommes
nous demeurons bien loin les uns des
autres
tu as un entresol alloué que dirais tu
de m'avoir pour le côté droit je pense
bien un ami com - sara bahrami
quel rôle joue mon dieu quelle religion
et puis vos sorts pour quant à kaba là
tout de suite j'emménage demain et je
couche après demain et du coup japonais
au diable c'est qu'après demain je ne
suis pas là ah non je suis absent toute
la journée et l'homme suis à vous un
héros mais tu n'as pas besoin de moi le
concierge jeu sera là pour installer
n'inquiète pas je vais me préparer ça
tout de suite merci le malheur le
mercredi soir soit mais qu'est ce que tu
écris il a dit c'est mon bail luis et
tomba la bomba monsieur le procureur de
la république et toi qu'est ce que tu
comptes fait exactement la même chose
que tu as fait pour moi le flagrant nuit
or à mon cher le mariage est une partie
de baccarat à lui des cartes là
maintenant
la pièce que nous avons eu le plaisir de
jouer devant vous et de georges feydeau
[Applaudissements]
les décors et les costumes sont de
claude catulle
la mise en scène de pierre mondy
[Applaudissements]
am et émergents
anne rodier
[Applaudissements]
l'un selon tabbou
alors que d'habitude
georges e montillet
françoise angèle
daniel prévost
[Applaudissements]
christiane muller
philippe dumas
[Applaudissements]
jacques balutin
hier doris
jean pierre darasse
celui des marais
[Applaudissements]
et après d'adam
[Musique]